SPEAKER 1: We are honored today
to have Irene Weisberg Zisblatt
with us to tell her story.
She is the author of a book
called "The Fifth Diamond."
Normally, you'd give a bio.
In this particular case,
she is going to talk.
And her book is just a
really great narrative
of her story, which is just
an amazing, amazing story
of her survival in the
Holocaust and her life.
So please join me
in welcoming Irene.
[APPLAUSE]
IRENE WEISBERG
ZISBLATT: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I got to take my Bible out.
This is my Bible.
Thank you so much for
having me here today.
First, I want to thank
Gilly and her husband
for making this
day happen for me.
Her husband Adam and Gilly are
my friends for a long time.
I also would like to extend my
very special thanks to Google
for helping me reach the
present and future readers
of "The Fifth Diamond."
The pages of my book tell
my personal experience.
You will learn about the darkest
part in history and humanity
at its worst.
While many people
want to forget,
it would certainly be
wiser to understand.
Through my account as a
witness to these crimes,
it is my hope to
demonstrate the strength
of my hope in human spirit, the
meaning of having faith in God,
and the memory of a
loving friendship.
I am a Holocaust
survivor of man's hatred.
I am the only
survivor of my family.
That places on me a double
duty to bear witness.
I remember when Hitler gave the
order that all Jewish people
must be exterminated.
We had no place to hide.
We were thrown out
of every country,
and our suffering did not end.
My mother was so
sad when she did not
see us children play
or smile anymore.
She tried to give us away, not
because she didn't love us,
but because she
tried to save us,
but there was no one
there to help her.
The SS took her, my father,
and all my siblings,
but they wouldn't
let me go with them.
I saw my family go into
the chamber of death.
My mother gave me her diamonds,
and that is the only connection
to her that I have.
I couldn't pray on that
day, but for some reason
they let me live.
It is now 71 years
after the Holocaust,
and still things like a
railroad track or a train
brings my yesterdays into today.
I like to share some
of my yesterdays
with you, not to
make you hate them,
but to tell you
what hatred does.
I am a Hungarian Jew.
The devastation
of Hungarian Jews
were the worst murdered of
men, women, and children
in the last days of the war.
When Hitler was facing defeat,
he brought the Holocaust
to Hungary.
I was living there in a
beautiful little resort
town in the mountains.
We were only 263 families,
and a third was only Jewish.
As far back as I can remember,
I had a great relationship
with my non-Jewish friends.
We didn't have any telephones
or iPods or computers,
but we had each other.
We children were always
together-- in the parks,
in the homes, and in schools.
The mountains we lived in had
the most natural resources
in all of Europe.
Mineral water was one of
them and still is today.
My father had a spa, and he
used this water for people
with muscular problems.
He devoted his life
to help everyone.
My siblings, my
friends, and I loved
living in these beautiful
mountains, but not far from us
in Germany, Hitler
was ending democracy
and was lining up his henchmen.
The SS, which were
the Stormtroopers--
the SS, the security
police and the Gestapo,
the special state police.
Our government was
an ally to Germany
and chose not to report
the Jewish people yet,
but ordered strict restrictions.
From 1939 until
1944, Hungarian Jews
were stripped of their
rights and entitlements
as they had never existed.
In addition, the men were
forced into labor units
where they were poorly
clothed, ill-fed,
and ultimately murdered.
At the age of nine, I was
thrown out of the one thing
that I loved most, my
school, because I was a Jew.
And from that day on, my life
changed, and so did the world.
My non-Jewish
friends ignored me.
My education and freedom
was taken away from me.
And my hopes were
destroyed by Nazi hatred.
We didn't see any
SS in our towns yet,
but the evil was
carried out by the Arrow
Cross, the Hungarian SS.
They were feared by all people.
Our food was running
out, and they wouldn't
let us buy in any store.
A curfew was enforced, and we
had to wear the yellow star.
I will never forget the
sadness in my parents' faces
when we children were hungry
and they had no food to give us.
Once, a cow wandered
into our backyard,
and my mother risked
her life during curfew,
climbed out the back
window, and milked the cow.
And that was the only
time that we had milk.
I was the oldest
of six children.
I had four brothers
and one sister.
Every day, the Nazis ordered
new restrictions for us.
After they stripped
us from our dignity,
they demanded our valuables.
I heard my mother
say to my father,
first they made our star
to a badge of shame,
and now they want to
rob us of our feelings
of being worthy enough of
owning something of value.
I think that my mother sewed
her diamonds into my skirt
to save our pride, and
then she gave them to me
with a purpose--
to buy bread if I am hungry.
In 1939, when
Poland was invaded,
a few men were able to escape
to us over the mountains.
My father with his friends
helped them to safety.
Their destination, Palestine.
I don't know if they ever
made it to Palestine,
but one night a man had to
spend the night in my home
because it wasn't safe to go on.
And I heard him beg my
father to take his family
and go with him because,
when the SS come to us,
they will kill our children
just like they do in Poland.
I couldn't sleep the
rest of the night.
In the morning,
the man was gone.
And I asked my father,
who are these SS,
and why are they
killing the children?
What have those children done?
And my father said,
the man wasn't himself.
He didn't know
what he was saying.
People don't do such things.
See, the most civilized country
in all of Europe, nobody
believed that they
did such things.
So we didn't go with the man.
We also didn't
believe that the Nazis
were going to come to us
because the war was almost over.
And besides, we were
in this little town
surrounded by mountains.
We didn't think that they
were going to come and bother
to look for so few of us.
And just then, my country was
trying to extricate itself
from the alliance with Germany.
And Hitler got so enraged
he ordered the army
to invade Hungary and deal
with the Jewish problem.
The next day, each person had
to pack a suitcase not exceeding
25 kilo and go to a ghetto.
I didn't even know
what a ghetto was,
but they made me feel that I had
to be punished for something.
They made me leave my
home for no reason at all.
The ghetto was a
brickyard, but there were
no bricks being manufactured.
There were just people
everywhere suffering.
When we got there, there
was no shelter left,
so my parents built a hut from
the tablecloths and sheets
that my mother packed
in her suitcase.
And they built a tent,
and that was our new home.
Once a day, they
allowed us to go
to the river that
surrounded the ghetto just
to drink a little water.
They wouldn't let us
wash our face or clothes.
We couldn't even take back
water to the little children
or the sick people.
We children were
always afraid to be
taken away from our
parents or being
beaten for no reason at all.
Every day, they took
men and boys to work.
Many of them never came back.
And then the cattle trains
came, and they told us
that we need to be relocated to
the vineyard in our own country
until after the war.
Well, everybody was so happy
to leave this hellish place
and go to the vineyard,
so everybody, my mother
[? still, ?] packed
up our suitcases.
And she reminded
me that if we work
in the vineyard
in separate places
and I get hungry to use
the diamonds to buy bread.
When I saw the cattle
trains, I asked my father,
why are we going to
work in cattle trains?
And my father said, the
vineyard isn't that far away.
It wouldn't be so bad.
But when they forced 100
people in each boxcar
with a small pail
with no water in it,
I knew that something
was very wrong.
When they locked the
doors from the outside,
we were in complete darkness.
A crack in the wall was
the only light we had.
My father was
standing by the crack
to see how far away we
are from the vineyard.
And the boxcar was so bad.
There was no room to
sit or stand or move.
We children, all
the children, were
sitting on the floor
against the wall
and holding our little
siblings in our laps
so the adults should
have a little more room
to move around.
And then my father
saw through the crack
that we are not going
to the vineyard,
and he said they lied to us.
We just left our country and we
crossed the border to Poland.
I was holding my two-year-old
little brother in my arms,
and he never stopped crying.
When my father said we
are going to Poland,
I remember the man that was
spending a night in our home,
and he told us to go with him
because when they come to us
they'll kill our
little children.
My little brother was crying
in my arms all the time--
not for food, not for water.
He just wanted to go home.
And I promised him that
we will be home soon.
But when my father said
we are going to Poland,
and I remembered what the man
said about the little children,
I held my little
brother so tight,
and I promised myself
that I will never
let the SS take him from me.
My little brother never
saw his home again.
We were in the boxcar
for about five days,
and the entire
time I was wishing
that the train
would stop so we can
go to a real bathroom
like normal people.
But most, I was
wishing that they
would give the children
some food and some water
and maybe they will stop crying.
And the boxcar was
so bad that when
the train stopped I thought
that we have survived the worst,
but I was wrong.
When the doors opened, the
SS with their vicious dogs
and clubs in their
hands, yelling at us,
get out you dirty Jews,
and make it quick.
They immediately separated
the men from the women.
They made us leave our
belongings at the train,
and they told us that the men
will bring it to us later.
We never saw our men or
our belongings ever again.
As we were passing
the cattle train,
I saw chimneys in the distance,
and I pointed them out
to my mother.
And I said, the factories
we are going to work in.
But my mother paid
no mind to me.
In this chaos, she was
trying to hold us together.
She took my little
brother from my arms,
and she told me to hold my
four-year-old little sister's
hand really tight so
she doesn't get lost.
A man in a striped
jacket came over,
and he offered to carry
my little brother,
but my mother didn't let him.
But she asked him, where are we?
And he said, Auschwitz.
But we didn't know
what Auschwitz was
or why we were there.
There were three long
cattle trains packed
with people waiting to get off.
And I again looked
at the chimneys,
and I couldn't believe that the
Nazis had so many factories,
that they needed so many of
us to come to work for them.
Little did I know that we were
the daily ration for the gas
chamber.
When Hitler declared the
assault on Hungarian Jews,
it was during the
Final Solution.
The Final Solution
then, that not one Jew
will survive to bear witness.
In 54 days, on
147 cattle trains,
437,402 Hungarian Jews
were in Auschwitz.
And that was only
from the little towns.
The big cities were long gone.
When we passed the cattle
trains, a handsome SS
man wearing white gloves and a
baton-like stick in his hand,
he appeared in front
of us, and he pointed
that stick at my mother.
And he yelled at her, put the
child down and go to the right.
But my mother being so
desperate to keep us
together, she
yelled back at him,
my children will go with me.
He got so angry at her
that she did not obey him,
he took that baton-like
stick and he hit my hand
between my little sister.
He separated us.
We were bleeding.
We were crying and begging him
to let me go with my mother.
But he just took my little
sister away and kicked me away
from them.
And then I heard my mother
call out to me, don't cry.
I will come for you later.
That was the last time I
heard my mother's voice.
A few minutes later, I was
in a huge hall with thousands
of people, but I was alone.
The SS men and women
with their vicious dogs
again yelling at us, take
your clothes and shoes off
and hold them in one hand.
And take your valuables
and put them in the bin.
And I remembered my
mother's diamonds
that she sewed them in
the hem of my skirt.
So I quickly took them out.
I don't know how many they
were, but I found four of them.
And they took our
belongings right away.
I didn't know, so I was holding
them in my hand really tight.
And when they moved us
to the next section,
I saw that they shaved their
hair, they took our name away,
tattooed a number in my arm.
And then I saw that they
were pulling gold teeth
from people's mouth.
I put my mother's
diamonds in my mouth
when they were shaving my
head so I can hide them.
But when I saw they were
looking in people's mouths
I knew that they will
find the diamonds.
They will take them away.
And they will shoot me for
not putting them in the bin.
So for fear, I
swallowed the diamonds.
So then I was safe.
I didn't have to worry about
going to the gas chamber
because I owned diamonds.
They after pushed us
into another room,
and there was a pile of clothes.
They ordered us
to take one piece.
I got a pajama top that
barely covered my body.
And at the door
was a huge mirror,
and they ordered us
to look at ourselves.
I didn't recognize
myself when I saw myself.
I was reduced to a number
that represented a nothing.
I was stripped of my
identity and my dignity.
But you see, that was
their first process
of dehumanizing us.
And then they lined
us up in rows of five
and marched us
into a place called
Birkenau, a planet of evil.
The SS locked the electric
barbed-wire fences behind us,
never to let us out.
It was spring, but flowers
and grass didn't grow there.
The sky was as gray as
the mud under my feet.
The wooden barracks
with three-story bunks
were our luxury housing.
1,000 of us in each barrack
and 10 of us in each bunk
didn't give us much
hope ever to get out.
Our food for the day was a cup
of brown liquid called soup.
It was seasoned with a
chemical that was destroying
our reproductive organs.
The twice-a-day roll call
wasn't just to take count,
but Doctor Josef Mengele's
haven for human guinea pigs
for his brutal experiments.
We were completely cut off
from the outside world.
At the end of the day, when
my mother didn't come for me,
I decided to go look for her
because with my hair shave,
with this piece
of rag on my body,
she will not be able to find me.
But when I got to the door,
the kapo slapped my face
and yelled at me,
where are you going?
And when I told her, she
pointed to the chimney,
and she said your mother is
just about now coming out
of one of those chimneys.
And if you don't go back to the
bunk, all of you will go there.
I was so scared.
I didn't understand why she was
saying that about my mother.
My mother was only 32 years
old, and she was beautiful.
Why would anyone do
this to my mother?
But I had no answers
to my questions.
So I climbed up to my bunk,
and I tried to go to sleep,
hoping that when I wake up
this madness will be gone.
But I couldn't fall
asleep because the cries
of little children were so sad.
We didn't have any
windows in our barracks,
but we had a three-inch
opening between the ceiling
and the wall.
So I was on the top
bunk, and I looked
at the three-inch
ceiling between the wall
and the ceiling.
And I looked out, and I saw
trucks coming down the road.
And two little children--
they were this little--
they fell out of the truck.
The SS men picked them
up by their little feet,
and then he just threw
them against a truck.
The blood was everywhere.
He threw them back on the truck
like they were no children,
like they were two
pieces of firewood.
Those little children
that committed no sin
will never, never cry again.
I was so hopeless I
didn't know what to do,
so I started to scream,
but the girl next to me
put her hand over
my mouth and she
begged me not to scream or even
talk because the punishment was
death.
So in my silence, I called
to God, but God wasn't there.
I was thinking,
where is he, and why
isn't he taking care of
those little children?
I was so angry with him.
I had the biggest
fight with him.
But then, I said to myself,
why am I fighting with God?
God didn't create the Holocaust.
Men did.
So in my silence, I figured it
out, that he must be in a place
where he is taking
care of other children.
And when he is
done, he will surely
come and take care of us.
The next day, I was selected
by Dr. Josef Mengele
for his brutal experiments.
I was no longer a
13-year-old child.
My childhood couldn't
continue in the death camps.
But in a desperate effort, I
had to try and save my mother's
diamonds that carried her love.
Once a day, we were allowed
to go to the latrine.
If you saw
"Schindler's List," you
know what the
latrine looked like.
I never had the pleasure of
sitting on one of those holes
because I had to
find a safe place
to save my mother's diamonds.
It would have been safer to
throw the diamonds away when I
realized that I cannot buy
bread, not even for diamonds.
But the love and the
pride that they carried
was stronger than Nazi hatred.
I saw hatred so strong that
when Mengele was experimenting
on us without anesthetics and
the pain was so unbearable,
I saw joys in his eyes
watching us suffer.
That kind of a hatred
existed in the 20th century
in Nazi Germany.
When the SS packed the
gas chambers with mothers
and fathers and sisters and
brothers and grandparents,
I was there.
I saw them, and I heard them
cry out for their last time.
Do not forget us,
[INAUDIBLE] Israel.
At that moment, my
will to live became
stronger and more important.
I promised to be their voice
if I survived this evil.
Those children's
voices were silenced
in the most unspeakable terror
of the Shoah, of the Holocaust,
just because their eyes
were not blue enough
or their skin was not white
enough or they were Jewish.
Those million and
a half children
are depending on us to carry
their message, never again.
When Nazi doctors
were torturing us
and the pain was
so unbearable, I
knew that we must endure
and live as long as we can
for those children.
During the experiments,
I had a silent friend.
Her name was Sabka.
Even in our pain, we could
not cry because the punishment
was death.
And then they took Sabka away.
And when she didn't come
back at the end of the day,
I just thought that they
took her to the gas chamber.
I was so lost without her.
And then they called
the selection,
and they selected 1,500
women, including myself,
to go to the gas chamber.
When we got there and
we started to go inside,
we realized that the gas
chamber wasn't big enough
to hold 1,500 people.
So everybody started
to push outside,
and I was pushed
back to the door.
So when I got to the
door, I dug my nails
into the side of the
door and I just hung on--
didn't want to be
pushed back inside.
Not that I was looking
for a miracle--
because nobody ever
came out of there--
but for that moment,
I just wanted
to look at the sky
for as long as I can.
And then the Zyklon B arrived,
and the SS ordered the guard
to close the door so they
can throw the Zyklon B.
But he was so nervous
because I was in the doorway
and he could not close the door,
and he must obey at any cost.
So he threw me out,
and he closed the door.
I ran up the ramp
that I just came down
looking for a place to hide,
but there was no place to hide.
But then, I saw that the gas
chamber had a little space
between the roof--
see, the gas chamber
was underground,
but the roof was on
top of the ground.
And between the
roof and the ground,
there was about this much space.
And I only weighed about
50 pounds at that time,
so I was able to crawl in
that little spot and hide.
While I was underneath,
I said to myself,
what's [? this ?] [? end? ?]
In about 20 minutes,
another transport will come in.
And they will find me.
They will put me back
in the gas chamber
with the people
that are coming in.
But for that moment, I had hope.
And then a Sonderkommando
boy came to do his job,
and he saw me first.
Do you know what a
Sonderkommando is?
Anybody?
OK.
A Sonderkommando is
a group of people
that Mengele and doctors
selected when the trains came
in from all parts of Europe.
From every part of Europe,
they would select the strongest
between the age of 18 and 35.
And their job was--
they were called
the Sonderkommando.
Their job was to appease the
people when they were leading
them into the gas chamber.
And when they were dead, their
job was to put them in the oven
and cremate them.
The only problem was
that they were only given
three to four months to live.
And after that, they would
take the Sonderkommando
and kill them and select
new ones that came in.
The reason they selected a
group from every country,
so they can speak the
language that the people
that they were appeasing.
Can you imagine?
There were over 8,000
people in the Sonderkommando
at all times.
And every three,
four months, they
would kill these strong,
beautiful, young people just
because they did their job.
And this one Sonderkommando
boy found me first.
He took his jacket off and
covered my naked body and said,
I'll be right back.
And I thought I was
hallucinating because I never
thought that these
things were happening.
It didn't take a few minutes.
He came back.
He took my hand, and he walked
me around the gas chamber.
And he says, there is a
train going to a labor camp.
I will try and put
you on that train.
I says, who are you?
I mean, what is your name
and where are you from?
He spoke my language.
He says, that doesn't matter.
I only have three
more days to live.
So if you make it, live
a little for me, too.
That is the time when I realized
how much I want to stay alive
for him and for all the others.
So he says, my name
is not important.
I'm not going to be here.
Can you imagine?
Killing all these people for
doing their dirty [? world. ?]
So he did put me on a train.
The train was moving
only at night.
I didn't know which way we were
going, where we were going.
But when the train stopped,
we were in a labor camp.
We were put in
barracks and in bunks
just like in Auschwitz
and Birkenau.
In the morning, when I
looked down at my lower bunk,
another miracle happened.
My silent friend Sabka was
looking straight at me.
You cannot imagine
what this was like.
We both thought that we were
taken to the gas chamber
and we were both dead, and here
we are in the same camp alive.
We didn't know whether we
were able to talk there
because how the punishment was
there, but we didn't have to.
We just looked at each
other, and we just
knew that from here on we
were going to be together
no matter where it takes us.
We worked in this factory.
It was a munition factory.
We were 5,000 women there.
And we worked in
separate places,
but we were together
every night.
We worked there until
January of 1945.
And in January of 1945,
they took all 5,000 women.
They gave us a pair of
wooden shoes that didn't fit
and a blanket, and they put
us out on the death march.
It was so cold.
The snow was up to our knees.
But the SS pushed us off
the road and left us there.
Whenever they wanted
to stop for themselves,
they would push us off the
road and let the dogs guard us.
And I don't know
what they were doing,
but I guess they needed a rest.
They were shooting
people every few miles
that they couldn't keep up
and left them on the wayside.
Sabka and I were so helpless.
We couldn't help them live,
and we couldn't help them die.
And then we were marching
from January until April.
By April, we were only 200 of
us left alive from the 5,000.
And we decided that we
were going to give up.
We were going to
sit on the road.
And if they tell us to
march and we don't march,
they are going to
have to shoot us.
But just then, planes appeared
from behind the mountains,
and they were bombing
everything that was moving.
But we were on this very
narrow farm road with forests
all around us,
and the only thing
that was moving on this
road was the trucks
that were carrying the
supplies for the guards.
So needless to say, they bombed
those trucks to smithereens.
And when they came back, they
ordered us to march again.
And I said to Sabka, I
don't want to march anymore,
so I'm going to sit
down on the road.
And I was going to wait
for somebody to shoot me.
But Sabka pulled
me into the lineup,
and she whispered
to me, look away
from what you see and
think about the world
that they took away from us.
So you can, you've got to go.
So I went.
And a few miles later,
I sat on the road again.
I just didn't want to go.
And I said, Sabka, I don't
know where we're going.
And when we get there, they're
going to shoot us anyway.
So why waste all this time?
And she says, I know
where we're going.
We're going to the library,
and we're going to read a book.
And then we're going to
go home, and we're going
to have dinner with our family.
And then we're going to
sleep in our own bed,
and we won't have to
share it with 10 people.
So you can't die today.
So these were words
that's Sabka and I
would tell each other
when one of us gave up,
and it kept us going.
And then finally, she
realized that, yes,
we are going to get killed, so
let's do something about it.
We were at such a dark night,
we couldn't even see each other.
I don't know how she found
out that the guards had
no flashlights and
they had no ammunition
because it was all
bombed on the truck.
She pushed me off the road,
and she jumped after me,
and she held my mouth.
And she says, wait
until everybody passes.
And so when everybody
passed, she says,
God created this dark
night so we can escape.
So I says, but I
don't want to escape.
I don't want to go anywhere.
They're going to catch us.
They're going to kill us.
She says, we must go.
We must find some real food
before we go to heaven.
I says, OK.
See, these were words
that kept us going.
So I kept going.
And so all night, we
were running and walking
as fast as we can.
At daybreak, I noticed
an abandoned farm.
So I ran and I started
digging in the ground.
And she says, what
are you doing?
I says, I'm looking
for the food that's
going to take us to heaven.
She says, in this mud?
I says, this is no mud.
This is an abandoned farm.
And my grandfather
had a farm, and I
know that during harvest
they left a lot of food
in the ground, so I'm
going to look for it.
And I found a little potato.
And I shared this
little potato with her.
I says, see, this
is the food that's
going to take us to heaven.
And then we heard water running,
so we found this little brook
with the cleanest water that
we have seen in a long time.
So needless to say, we
drank a lot of water.
We were so rich.
We had this little potato
and this clean water.
So we decided to stay
by the brook and rest.
We covered ourselves
with this half a blanket
that we had left because
the other half we
had to cut pieces
and wrap up our feet
when we lost the wooden
shoes in the snow.
But that's OK.
We only weighed about
50 pounds each or less,
so we wrapped ourselves
up in this little blanket
and we fell asleep.
I don't know how long we slept,
but someone was poking me
with the back of a rifle.
And Sabka says, I am not
coming out of the blanket.
I don't want to see who
is going to shoot us.
And I said Sabka--
see, Sabka was a
little older than me,
so she was a little wiser.
But I had more dare, and
I didn't care anymore.
So I said, Sabka, let
go of the blanket,
and I'm going to see
who's going to shoot us.
When I put my head
out, I saw two soldiers
in strange uniforms
and strange boots,
and they spoke a
strange language.
I spoke seven
languages at that time
and I didn't understand them.
And when I spoke to them, they
didn't understand me either.
They were looking at me
with such a disbelief.
God knows, I didn't look human.
My eyes were bulging
out of my head.
My bones were sticking
out of my skin.
I was covered with
lice and dirt.
I weighed about 50 pounds.
And one of the soldiers
was bending to--
I don't know whether he
wanted to help me up,
but his dog tags fell
out of his shirt.
And on the dog tags, he had a
little tiny 10 Commandments.
And I said, Sabka, come
out of the blanket.
There is another Jew here.
And she said, who is he?
I says, I don't know.
She goes, I'm not coming
out of the blanket.
So you see, at that
point, Sabka and I
thought we were the only two
Jewish people in all of Europe
that is alive.
So the soldier helped me up.
He put his 10 Commandments
in my hand, and I kissed it
So he, at that point,
kind of guessed who I was,
but he didn't know
exactly who I was.
And he motioned for me to stay,
and he took off with his buddy.
A few minutes
later, a whole army
was coming down that
mountain towards me,
and they had a
German-speaking soldier,
so I was able to communicate.
And he looked at me, and he
said, who are you hiding from,
and why do you look like this?
God knows I didn't look human.
And I tried to explain
to him about the death
camps and the death march and
that the Nazis are doing this.
He says, what kind of
people do this to children?
And I again tried to explain.
He didn't know what
I was talking about,
knew nothing about that.
And I was angry.
I didn't know who they were,
and Sabka wouldn't come out
of the blanket.
And I was afraid that maybe they
are not who I think they are.
And I got angry with him.
And I says, who are you?
And he goes, don't be afraid.
We are Americans.
And I didn't believe him.
I says, Americans?
What are you doing here?
Don't you know
what's going on here?
He says, yeah, we do, and that's
why we're here-- to stop it.
And he tried to convince me
to believe him who he is.
He says, Germany is burning,
and we're going to go to Berlin
and kill Hitler.
And this will never
going to happen again.
You will never have
to be afraid of.
I said, OK.
So I started to believe him.
So at that point, I
looked up to heaven,
and I said, thank you,
God, for watching over us.
I cannot find the words
high enough to describe
my liberators, but they helped
us to believe that there are
still people in this
world that care.
I saw so much love
in their eyes.
I wanted to hug them and
thank them for finding us,
but I was so dirty and
covered with lice I didn't
want them to be like that.
And then he said, would you
like to have something to eat?
God knows we looked hungry.
And that's when Sabka
came out of the blanket--
not because he wanted to eat
first, but she asked them,
can we have just a
little scrambled eggs
and a small loaf of bread?
So our wish becomes a reality.
Because that's what we were
talking about on the death
march and in the death camp--
of our favorite foods and the
world they took away from us.
And that's what kept
us going all this time.
Within minutes, there was little
fires all over the mountains
because we couldn't build a big
fire because we were in danger.
You know, the war was still on.
But they built
these little fires,
and they were scrambling
eggs in their helmets.
They didn't have any
bread, so they gave me
these brown little boxes.
And they opened
them up, and there
were lots of crackers in
there and these brown chunks
of things.
I didn't know what they were.
They turned out to be
chocolate, but I never
saw chocolate before.
So I didn't care about
that, but I was very happy
with the crackers.
And Sabka was very happy
with her scrambled eggs.
And then they gave
us clean shirts,
and we went back to the
brook and washed ourselves
and put on those clean shirts.
And they put us in
a Red Cross van.
And again, they made our
wish become a reality.
There were two beds with pillows
and blankets and white sheets.
We weren't sure that that was
for us, so we sat on the floor.
But then, after a
while, no one came in,
so we just realized that
they must be for us.
You cannot imagine it.
It was the greatest
feeling to know
that we will not have to
share this bed with 10 people.
We started to think
about our families,
and we knew that we will
never see them again.
So the feeling was different.
We weren't so happy anymore.
We just sat and we
cried and cried,
and we just cried
ourselves to sleep.
In the morning, when I woke
up, Sabka was still sleeping.
I was calling her name,
and I yelled at her, Sabka,
get up because today is the
day we will start our new life
in the free world, together.
But she didn't wake up.
A soldier came in
to tell us to get
ready to leave because the enemy
was closing in on that area,
and we were in their way.
So I asked him, please
help her wake up.
Because she is so tired, she
can't wake up by herself.
And when he saw her, he opened
the door and he yelled, medic.
And the medic came in.
And I saw that he
gave her an injection,
but she didn't wake up.
So I yelled at him, wake her up.
Don't let her sleep so long.
And he says, I
can't wake her up.
She is sleeping in a
very beautiful place,
and she is no longer
sick or hungry.
And she knows that you are free.
I said, what are you saying?
She was never sick.
And he said, she was very sick.
She died in her sleep of
typhus, and I can't help her.
Please, tell me, where
do you want her body
to be buried because
we really must go.
But my heart was so full of
grief, I questioned myself--
if I could have done something
to help her stay alive.
The loss was so unbearable.
Again I was losing
my loved ones.
She was going to be the
friend and my family forever,
and now I am again alone.
I couldn't even spend
time at her graveside
because we were in harm's
way and we had to go.
We buried her in the blanket
that we were liberated in,
and we buried her also in the
spot where we were liberated.
And the soldiers told me that
they will make arrangements
for the soldiers that
are coming after that
to come back after
the war and take
her body to a real cemetery.
And we did that, but we
couldn't find her body
because the mountain was
so destroyed from fighting.
She is in my heart all the time.
And they took me with
them, and they left me
in a field hospital somewhere
in the mountains near
[? Pilsen, ?] and they
went on to fight the war.
And when I got stronger, they
put me in a displaced person
camp where I joined
40 children to go
to Sweden to an orphanage.
And while I was waiting
to go to Sweden,
my name appeared on a list
of survivors in New York.
And my father had a brother in
the Bronx that I never knew.
And he saw the name on the
survival list, my name,
and he wrote a letter and
asked the camp to find me
and asked me if I want
to come to a free country
and a new family.
And I screamed so loud
they must have heard
me all the way to New York.
So I gave up my spot to
another child to go to Sweden,
and I waited two years
to go to America.
I couldn't believe
that I was going
to the greatest free
country in the whole world.
And finally, in 1947,
I saw about what
a free country looks like for
the first time in my life.
After many encounters
with death,
I survived Hitler's atrocity.
And now, I must rebuild my life.
But first, I must find a way
to be the voice that I promised
to be for those children.
But I couldn't, because
who was going to believe
such a nightmare, a child?
So that was one of the reasons
that I did not share my past
in the Holocaust for 50 years.
I couldn't tell of my torturers
that destroyed my temples,
my Torahs, and humanity itself.
But then in 1994 when
"Schindler's List" came out,
and I knew that it is
my duty to bear witness,
it was difficult to describe
so much sorrow and pain.
Even in my free world, my
nightmares were the same,
except the ashes were grayer,
the cries were louder,
and the children's
pain was clearer.
When I woke up, I had to force
myself to think where I was.
So how can I be the voice
that I promised to be?
I tried to think
about my tomorrows
because my yesterdays were all
about Auschwitz and Birkenau.
And then I thought of the camps.
With my experience, maybe they
could be lessons for humanity.
So I must learn
from my yesterdays
and share them with the
present and future generation.
Since I was only 13 years old
when I endured so much pain,
and I witnessed so much
injustice against humanity,
I knew that the
children of tomorrow
could learn from my pain.
So, in 1994 after
"Schindler's List" came out,
I realized that it is
my duty to bear witness.
So I went back to the death
camps with 5,000 teenagers
from 49 countries on
the March of the Living.
50 years after the Holocaust, I
was back in Auschwitz-Birkenau
on the planet of evil where
I lost my entire family,
and I was a human guinea
pig for Dr. Josef Mengele.
When I saw how much
evidence the SS destroyed,
I was so angry I
wanted to kill someone.
But most of all, I
wanted to yell at Mengele
because he always yelled at us.
I looked around
because I didn't want
to yell in front
of the children,
and what used to be the
gypsy camp were still
a couple of barracks
that were not destroyed.
So I went inside
one of them, and I
yelled as loud as I could
at Mengele, look at me.
I am alive.
In spite of your
experiments, you
tortured Sabka and I
and millions of people
you sent to the flames.
I am back with 5,000
healthy children,
and you can't touch us.
Since there is no room
for hatred in my life,
that was my revenge.
And from there, I went to the
number 2 gas chamber where
my entire family was murdered.
And again, I was angry.
What used to be the gas chamber
is now a pile of rubble.
I found an opening in that
rubble, and I crawled inside.
50 years on the anniversary
of the Holocaust,
I was again in the gas chamber.
The walls were
still green and blue
from the Zyklon B. The
smell is still very strong,
and the fear of death
still embraced me.
I sat down on the ground
and lit all my candles
that I had in my backpack,
and I prayed for the victims
that died such a cruel death.
As I was leaving
the gas chamber,
I turned around one
more time to look back,
and I saw a table
set for dinner.
Actually, it was set for our
first Seder, for our holiday.
And my whole family was
sitting around the table,
and next to my little
sister was an empty chair.
And that was my chair.
So I turned around, and I was
going to go sit in my chair,
but my mother put her hand
in front of me and she says,
you can't sit in your chair yet.
Promise me that you
will stop crying
and you will do what you must.
When I reached out to hug
her, she wasn't there.
So I sat down by my candles
and I wrote her a letter,
and I'd like to share
the letter with you.
I will not cry anymore,
and I will never
forget the children who died a
cruel death because their eyes
were not blue enough, or
their skin not light enough,
or they were Jewish.
I will never forget the
painful look in their eyes
when they marched
to their death.
Dear mother, this letter I am
writing to you is very special.
I want to tell you
how much I miss you.
I missed you on my wedding
day, and you did not
share my happiness.
But most, I missed
you when I gave birth
to your grandchildren and
you could not hold them.
It is difficult to
live with the fact
that you were cheated
of enjoying them.
As for me, being a mother
today, I can feel the pain
you felt when your children
died in your arms from the gas.
For me, there is no medicine
I can take to heal my pain.
I am still learning
to live with it.
But I promise you to tell
the world all that happened,
and I hope that God will
help me to stay strong.
And I pray that he watches
over our children of tomorrow
so they can remember the past
and never be silent when they
see injustice against people.
What happened to us
should never happen again.
And on this day, I am
making a commitment
to help heal the
sickness of hatred.
And when I can't help heal any
more, I hope to sit in my chair
and tell them that they
are being learned from.
When I came up from
the gas chamber,
I shared my past with
all these teenagers
from 49 countries for the
first time in 50 years.
I was grateful for the courage
and also the liberation
of this road of murder where SS
trained me to step over death
and not to cry for them.
Today, I want to tell them,
I survived your atrocities
and I cry for the death,
and I walk among people
that value human lives.
And I have not
stopped ever since.
After that day, I have
spoken to many, many people
from almost all the free world,
including our government.
I still can't believe
that I am alive today
and I shared my painful
past with the most powerful
government in the world.
But sharing my past with
you is most important
because you are going to be
that government in the future,
and it's going to be
up to you to make sure
that everyone is free to
practice their beliefs.
So if you remember
the Holocaust,
you will not let
it happen again.
The Holocaust is not
just a part in history,
but it lingers in the present--
in Rwanda, in Bosnia, in Africa,
in our own country, 9/11.
Perhaps when we were forgetting
how powerful hatred can be,
9/11 reminded us, and we
tasted violence and mass death.
So we must absolutely
be aware of hatred
and change people's
minds of hating others.
Otherwise, it will cause
another unexplainable event
like the Holocaust.
We must learn the
lessons of the Holocaust
to bring awareness of this
unfairness to humanity
and never forget
what hatred leads to.
If we stand up against
prejudice and promote tolerance,
it will change
lives and behaviors.
We must work together to protect
the future of human existence
for generations to
come, and it has
to start with our
future generation.
They are the first
generation at a distance
of the Holocaust and
the last generations
to know survivors firsthand.
None of their children will
be able to meet a survivor,
so they have a very
important mission.
To teach their children what
they learn from a survivor.
I need them to help me to
bring a good understanding
about this painful event.
When I am no longer here, I hope
that they will carry my message
to the future so those fires
of hell become a light of hope.
All the technological
devices my generation
had created in our
lifetime, we failed
to create a tool to stop hatred.
But we will help you to find
that tool as long as we're
here, and you will change that.
You will change the world.
So my mission is to
help you find that.
It was very easy for
Hitler to take our lives,
but it is difficult for us to
get Hitler out of our lives.
So please, join my children and
grandchildren, who will tell
and retell of our losses and
grief in hope to stop genocide.
I will not be silent, and I
will not forget the victims.
As long as I am able,
I will speak worldwide
to improve human conditions.
My goal is to make a difference
in one person every time
I share my past.
I cannot explain that
dark time in my childhood,
but we must remember it.
It is important
to recall the past
so our lives and generations
to come have more meaning.
The memory and the
lessons of the Holocaust
are not negotiable and not
a subject to be forgotten.
I relive my pain again
and again so present
and future generations
can learn from it.
I hope that they will learn
and remember and never
let it happen again.
I came forward to share my
degrading experience in hopes
that my personal story
will influence generations
to come to work together
and work for tolerance
and understanding.
I don't want the world to forget
what happened to us because I
don't want it to happen again.
For too long, hatred,
fear, and intolerance
have torn apart families,
communities, and nations
around the world.
If our world is to
achieve lasting peace,
all people must
learn that even if we
come from different
backgrounds, races, and culture,
we all have the same
dreams for our children.
The world has not learned
yet from past histories--
not just the Holocaust, but
histories before the Holocaust.
I cannot explain the Auschwitz
and Birkenau and the genocide
of Jews and others, but this
painful event teaches us what
is important in life.
So no matter how small
you think you are,
you can make the
biggest difference.
So embrace the past
and learn from it.
In spite of the chemicals in my
soup and Mengele's experiments,
I have a 6-foot-tall
gorgeous son
and a beautiful,
beautiful daughter
and five grandchildren
that light up
my life every single day.
My mother's diamonds and I
survived Hitler's atrocities,
and they are to be handed
down to each firstborn girl
in every generation to
preserve my mother's memory.
They are not to
be sold or traded.
Except, god forbid, if they're
hungry, they can buy bread.
So thank you so, so much
for having me here today.
Before I end, I want to thank
two very special people again.
Gilly and Adam and
Google, the company,
whoever you are and
as many as you are.
And if you have
any questions, I'll
be happy to answer if I can.
So where is my helper?
[APPLAUSE]
Before I let him go and
before he goes anywhere,
I'd like to pin him with a pin.
We have to earn it.
We get it on the
March of the Living.
And it's a pin.
It's a Hebrew word,
and it says Zakar.
Zakar means remember.
So I want to pin
him with this pin
because he remembered to get me
all these things to say today.
So thank you so much.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
IRENE WEISBERG
ZISBLATT: Oh, maybe I
have it on the wrong side.
SPEAKER 1: Perfect.
It's perfect.
Thank you again.
I think that we are--
if you have to leave,
we understand that time is over.
However, I would love
the opportunity for folks
to ask questions, and
we have a few minutes.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I just
want to say thank you
so much for sharing your story.
I can't imagine the strength
and the courage it takes,
and it's so selfless of you
to share it with everyone.
So thank you so much.
And Shanah Tovah.
IRENE WEISBERG ZISBLATT:
Shanah Tovah to you.
AUDIENCE: I was
just wondering, you
were 13 years old when you
went through this experience.
And throughout the talk,
you were describing
your relationship with God.
How did you rationalize
all of the hatred
that you went
through, and how are
you able to hold on to
your relationship with God
and have hope?
IRENE WEISBERG ZISBLATT:
I held on to words,
very important words.
Don't give up.
Fight.
Stay alive as long as you can.
And Sabka and I, we were
each other's strength.
If I gave up, she would
find words for say to me.
Like, for an example,
one day I said
I want to go through
the electric wires.
I want to die.
And she says, no, no,
no, you can't do that.
Just imagine, she says.
This hell cannot last forever.
And when it's over, the
world will be so beautiful.
Don't you want to stay
alive for just one minute
to see that beautiful world?
So those are the
things, those are
the kind of things
that helped us
push each hour to stay alive.
I could never imagine
being alive tomorrow,
but I was hoping and
pushing for today.
And there was no man
or woman anywhere
that can help me to be
here today except God,
and I never lost faith in God.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much
for speaking with us today.
I had a question.
Just sort of, I've
noticed over many years
of discussing politics
and current events
with people, a sort
of constant refrain
that people immediately
jump to when
they tend to dislike a
politician or a government
or are upset.
They frequently, immediately
compare them to the Nazis
because they know
everyone agrees
that they're the personification
of evil in many ways.
But I always wondered,
from your perspective,
does that upset you?
Do you think that sort
of does a disservice
to sort of discussion?
I mean, do you think it's
disrespectful for people
to sort of paint
with brush strokes
when they don't like
something, immediately to jump
to that as a characterization?
IRENE WEISBERG ZISBLATT:
Does it upset me?
It makes me sick and
afraid, and it takes me back
to my childhood where I wasn't
allowed or I wasn't giving
or I wasn't able to do anything.
Of course it does, and I wish
I can do something about it.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
All right, last question
in the back there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much for
this gift and for being here.
I have two questions.
How did you, after
experiencing these atrocities,
find joy in your life?
You mentioned prayer.
Do you pray?
Do you have a prayer practice?
IRENE WEISBERG ZISBLATT: Yes.
I pray all the time, and
I talk to God every Friday
night when I light candles.
I tell him my problems.
I ask him to fix
it, and he does.
I really believe that he does.
As far as my joy, I did not
have joy for a long time.
The first time I had joy is
when I gave birth to my family--
my son, my daughter, and
then my grandchildren.
Those are my joys.
That is the most
important thing in my life
because I lost my
family at a young age--
of 49 people in five minutes.
And I was alone ever since then.
And so this family is the most
important thing in my life.
And I have a lot
of joy from them.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
Well, again, on behalf of
Google, thank you so much,
Irene, for coming and
sharing your story today.
IRENE WEISBERG ZISBLATT:
Thank you for having me.
SPEAKER 1: I'd
recommend to anyone,
she goes into more detail
in "The Fifth Diamond."
It's a book.
IRENE WEISBERG ZISBLATT: Yeah.
I have books back there.
Whoever wants a
book, you're welcome.
SPEAKER 1: But thank you
for sharing your experience.
IRENE WEISBERG ZISBLATT:
Thank you, sir.
SPEAKER 1: You're doing a
great job on your mission.
IRENE WEISBERG
ZISBLATT: I hope so.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.
I love you.